JUST HOW SOPHISTICATED THE
SURVEILLANCE EQUIPMENT ONBOARD
WAS.
>>> WELCOME TO "THE LEAD" I'M
JAKE TAPPER.
AND WE START WITH THE WORLD LEAD
AND NEW INFORMATION ABOUT THE
CHINESE SPY BALLOON SHOT DONE.
IT STARTED ANALYZING THE FIRST
PIECES OF ITS BALLOON, AND
SENIOR OFFICIALS SAY THOSE PARTS
COULD BE USED AS EVIDENCE IN A
FUTURE POSSIBLE CRIMINAL CASE
AGAINST GROUPS LINKED TO THE
CHINESE MILITARY.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
DETERMINED THE BALLOON WAS
CAPABLE OF MONITORING U.S.
COMMUNICATIONS, BUT SOURCES SAY
U.S. OFFICIALS BELIEVE THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT DID NOT HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GATHER MUCH
INTELLIGENCE BECAUSE THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT STOPPED TRANSMISSIONS
TO THE CHINESE MAINLAND ONCE THE
U.S. FOUND OUT ABOUT THE
BALLOON.
HOUSE AND SENATE LAWMAKERS WERE
BRIEFED ON THE SPY BALLOON TODAY
INCLUDING THE PRESIDENT'S
DECISION TO LET IT FLY ACROSS
THE COUNTRY BEFORE SHOOTING IT
DOWN.
A TOP SENATE DEMOCRAT WHO LED
TODAY'S HEARINGS IS GOING TO
JOIN US IN JUST A FEW MINUTES.
BUT WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
CNN'S ALEX MARQUARDT.
>> Reporter: THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND PENTAGON
FACING A BIPARTISAN BARRAGE OF
QUESTIONS TODAY ON CAPITOL HILL
OVER THE CHINESE SURVEILLANCE
BALLOON.
>> YOU GUYS HAVE TO HELP ME
UNDERSTAND WHY THIS BABY WASN'T
TAKEN OUT LONG BEFORE BECAUSE I
AM TELLING YOU THAT -- THAT THIS
AIN'T THE LAST TIME.
WE SAW BRIEF INCURSIONS.
>> Reporter: ACCUSED OF A LACK
OF ALARM AND CRITICISM TO NOT
SHOOT DOWN THE BALLOON SOONER
WHEN IT WAS NEAR ALASKA.
>> THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
ALASKA IS THE FIRST LINE OF
DEFENSE FOR AMERICA.
>> Reporter: IN FOUR DIFFERENT
OFTEN TENSE HEARINGS
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS STOOD
BY THEIR ARGUMENT IT WAS SAFER
TO LET THE BALLOON CROSS THE
COUNTRY WHILE ALSO GATHERING
INTELLIGENCE ON CHINESE
CAPABILITIES.
MANY DEMOCRATS SATISFIED, MANY
REPUBLICANS STILL REJECTING THE
WHITE HOUSE AND PENTAGON'S
POSITION.
>> NEXT TIME, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
NOT GOING TO WAIT FOR IT TO
TREND -- GO ALL ACROSS MY STATE,
ALL ACROSS THE LOWER 48 AND THEN
SHOOT IT DOWN.
>> Reporter: OFFICIALS NOW TELL
CNN THERE WAS A WARNING.
THE DEFENSE INTELLIGENCE AGENCY
THE DIE BEFORE THE BALLOON
ENTERED U.S. AIRSPACE NEAR
ALASKA WHEN IT DID ON JANUARY
28th FIGHTER JETS WERE SENT UP
TO I.D. THE BALLOON BUT IT
DECIDED TO LET IT FLY ON AND
COLLECT INTELLIGENCE ON IT.
SUDDENLY OFFICIALS SAID IT TOOK
A STRANGE TURN SOUTH TOWARDS THE
LOWER 48 STATES CROSSING INTO
IDAHO ON JANUARY 31st AND
EASTWARD TO CROSS THE COUNTRY.
AFTER IT WAS DECIDED TO NOT
SHOOT THE BALLOON DOWN OVER
LAND, U2 SPY PLANES WERE SENT UP
TO MONITOR IT, THE
ADMINISTRATION DETERMINING THAT
THE BALLOON WAS NO LONGER
SENDING INFORMATION BACK TO
CHINA, SOURCES SAY AS THE U.S.
TRIED TO BLOCK IT FROM GATHERING
MORE INTELLIGENCE ON SENSITIVE
U.S. MILITARY SITES.
THIS BALLOON JUST A SMALL PART
OF A BROADER YEARS LONG CHINESE
BALLOON PROGRAM WHOSE FLEET THE
STATE DEPARTMENT SAYS FLEW OVER
MORE THAN 40 COUNTRIES.
>> THE UNITED STATES WAS NOT THE
ONLY TARGET OF THIS BROADER
PROGRAM WHICH HAS VIOLATED THE
SOVEREIGNTY OF COUNTRIES ACROSS
THE PROVINCE.
>> Reporter: CHINA OUTRAGED OF
THE SHOOTDOWN, DEMANDING THE
RETURN OF THE REMNANTS OF THE
BALLOON, THE U.S. REFUSING.
INSTEAD SENDING THE RECOVERED
PIECES FROM THE OCEAN TO AN FBI
LAB WHERE ANALYSIS HAS BEGUN.
SO FAR THAT INCLUDES THE CANOPY,
WIRING, AND SOME ELECTRONICS.
AND JAKE, WE LEARNED TODAY THAT
THE BALLOON WAS CARRYING
SOPHISTICATED ELECTRONICS
CAPABLE OF SURVEILLANCE OF
SIGNALS LIKE COMMUNICATIONS AND
RADAR.
SO FAR WHAT THE FBI HAS
COLLECTED HAS JUST BEEN WHAT WAS
ON THE SURFACE OF THE WATER JUST
OFF OF SOUTH CAROLINA.
AN FBI OFFICIAL SAYS THEY
HAVEN'T YET SEEN THE PAYLOAD
WHERE MOST OF THAT SURVEILLANCE
EQUIPMENT WOULD BE.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THE FBI
HAS INVESTIGATED A SPY BALLOON
LIKE THIS, AND OFFICIALS SAY
THEY'RE ANALYZING THE COMPONENTS
OF THE BALLOON FOR POSSIBLE
CRIMINAL CHARGES.
>> ALL RIGHT, ALEX MARYARDT.
JOINING US TO DISCUSS IS THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS ON DEFENSE, WHICH
SHOWS TODAY'S PUBLIC HEARING ON
THE CHINESE BALLOON, AND ALSO IN
MONTANA.
DID YOU SEE IT YOURSELF?
>> I DID NOT SEE IT MYSELF.
THERE WERE PLENTY OF PEOPLE WHO
SAW IT IN MONTANA.
>> AND YOU'RE UPSET ABOUT IT.
>> WE DID HAVE ICBMs IN MONTANA.
THEY DON'T LIKE ANYBODY SPYING
ON THEM MUCH LESS THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST GOVERNMENT, AND SO,
CRAW, IT'S A BIG DEAL.
WHAT CHINA DID WAS A MAJOR SCREW
UP AND INCURSION ON OUR
AIRSPACE, AND NO, I AM VERY
UPSET ABOUT IT.
I'VE HEARD FOR YEARS CHINA IS A
THREAT AND THEY ARE BOTH
ECONOMICALLY AND MILITARILY.
I THINK WE NEED TO TAKE THIS
SERIOUSLY.
THIS IS A BAD ACTION.
>> YEAH, SOME OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES, REPUBLICANS, HAVE
SAID IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN SHOT
DOWN EARLIER.
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE SAID THE
PENTAGON SAID IF WE SHOOT IT
DOWN OVER LAND IT RUNS THE RISK
OF HURTING PEOPLE, MONTANANS OR
30,000 PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THE
ISLANDS IN ALASKA.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
YOU THINK THEY SHOULD HAVE SHOT
IT DOWN EARLIER?
>> I THINK THE MILITARY MADE A
DECISION THAT THAT WASN'T THE
BEST OPTION, THE BEST OPTION WAS
TO DO WHAT THEY DID.
THEY HAD GOOD REASON FOR WHAT
THEY DID.
THEY EXPLAINED IT TO US IN
CLASSIFIED SESSION AND IN OPEN
SESSION HEARING THAT I HELD.
AND I ACCEPT THAT DECISION AS A
DECISION THAT WAS THE RIGHT
DECISION FOR THEM TO MAKE AT THE
TIME.
I WILL TELL YOU WHAT CONCERNS
ME, THOUGH.
I CHAIR I THE DEFENSE
APPROPRIATIONS WITH SENATOR
COLLINS.
WE NEED TO GET TOGETHER AND MAKE
SURE THE BUDGET MEET THE NEEDS
TO MAKE SURE THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN.
>> NEXT TIME THEY SEND THIS OVER
BECAUSE THE NEXT TIME IT HAPPENS
THERE NEEDS TO BE A PLAN TO TAKE
IT DOWN AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
>> I BELIEVE SO, YES.
OR YOU TAKE IT OUT OF THE SKY.
>> I WANT TO RUN A LITTLE OF THE
SOUND YOU SAID EARLIER TODAY
ABOUT THE THREAT THIS POSED TO
THE U.S.
>> TO KNOW ABSOLUTELY THAT THIS
WAS OF NO MILITARY THREAT TO US,
I WANT TO HEAR ABOUT THAT IN
CLASSIFIED SESSION, TOO, BECAUSE
QUITE FRANKLY, I'M NOT SURE THAT
YOU CAN SAY THAT TYPICALLY.
>> SO NOW YOU'VE HAD THE
CLASSIFIED SESSION.
I KNOW YOU CAN'T TELL US
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION, BUT DO
YOU FEEL THERE WAS NO MILITARY
THREAT?
>> I AM MUCH MORE COMFORTABLE
WITH THE EXPLANATION OF WHAT
THEY COLLECTED, AS TO BEING LET
ME PUT IT THIS WAY IT DOESN'T
PUT OUR NATIONAL SECURITY AT
RISK.
>> ONE OF THE PENTAGON OFFICIALS
YOU'RE HEARING SAY IT COULD BE
DAYS OR WEEKS BEFORE ALL THE
DEBRIS IS RECOVERED FROM THE
OCEAN.
WHEN WILL THE PUBLIC GET ANSWERS
ABOUT WHAT THIS BALLOON WAS
SPECIFICALLY DOING AND WHAT WAS
COLLECTED?
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW THAT -- I
DON'T KNOW THE PUBLIC WILL EVER
GET THE ANSWERS.
THAT WILL BE UP TO THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, BUT I
WILL SAY THIS THERE'S A LOT OF
SMART GUYS THAT WORK IN OUR
MILITARY AND INTEL.
THEY'RE GOING TO COLLECT IT.
THEY'LL PUT IT BACK TOGETHER,
THEY'LL REVERSE ENGINEER IT AND
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE DOING,
BUT IT'LL PROBABLY TAKE SOME
TIME.
THEY SAID THEY HAD A GOOD NIGHT
LAST NIGHT PICKING UP MATERIAL
FROM THE DOWNED BALLOON.
THE WEATHER EVIDENTDANTLY WILL
DETEERT, BUT, LOOK, THERE'S ONE
THING I KNOW ABOUT THE MILITARY.
THEY ARE GOING TO GO OUT,
THEY'LL GET EVERY STICK OF THAT
BALLOON AND CARGO THEY CAN AND
THEY'LL PUT IT BACK TOGETHER AND
THEY'LL MAKE A DETERMINATION
THAT WILL BE RIGHT FOR THIS
COUNTRY.
IT WILL TAKE SOME TIME, THOUGH.
I THINK THE BIGGER ISSUE HERE,
JAKE, IS THAT THIS IS AN
INCURSION ON OUR AIRSPACE, AND
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN A SITUATION
WHERE WE'VE SAID NO.
WE'VE SCRAMBLED FIGHTERS, WE'VE
DONE ALL SORTS OF STUFF AND THIS
IS A BALLOON.
IT'S NOT A FIGHTER AIRCRAFT,
IT'S NOT A BOMBER, BUT
NONETHELESS IT'S STILL AN
INCURSION OF OUR AIRSPACE AND
IT'S ILLEGAL.
>> DO YOU THINK PRESIDENT XI OF
CHINA WAS TESTING PRESIDENT
BIDEN, SEEING HOW HE WOULD
REACT, SEEING IF HE WAS STRONG
OR WEAK, ALL THAT?
>> I DON'T THINK THIS HAPPENED
BY MISTAKE.
I THINK THEY KNEW EXACTLY WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
WHETHER XI KNEW IT OR SOMEBODY
ELSE KNEW IT, THIS DIDN'T HAPPEN
BY ACCIDENT.
AND I THINK CHINA ALWAYS TESTS
US AND MAYBE TESTS US TO SEE
WHAT THE POLITICAL FALLOUT WAS
GOING TO BE, WHETHER FOLKS
PLAYED POLITICS WITH NATIONAL
DEFENSE, WHICH IS SOMETHING
WE'VE NEVER DONE, BUT WE DID SEE
SOME OF THAT WITH THIS SITUATION
OR HOW THE MILITARY WAS GOING TO
REACT.
AS I SAID THIS WASN'T THE FIRST
TIME A BALLOON HAS CROSSED INTO
OUR AIRSPACE IN DIFFERENT
ADMINISTRATIONS, AND WE NEED TO
HAVE A PLAN FOR THAT BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY IT'S NOT GOING TO
STOP.
AND I THINK OUR AIRSPACE IS
SACRED TO US, AND WE OUGHT TO
PROTECT IT.
>> LISTEN TO PRESIDENT BIDEN ASK
WHAT THIS WHOLE SAGA HAS DONE TO
U.S.-CHINA RELATIONS.
>> HAVE RELATIONS NOW BETWEEN
THE U.S. AND CHINA TAKEN A BIG
HIT?
>> NO.
NO.
THE IDEA OF SHOOTING DOWN A
BALLOON THAT'S GATHERING
INFORMATION OVER AMERICA AND
THAT MAKES RELATIONS WORSE?
>> DO YOU AGREE THAT U.S. AND
CHINA RELATIONS HAVE NOT TAKEN A
BIG HIT BECAUSE OF THIS?
>> I DON'T THINK CHINA RELATIONS
WERE PARTICULARLY GOOD BEFORE.
THE ONLY PROOF I FIND, JAKE, IS
THAT THEY'RE EQUIVALENT TO
SECRETARY AUSTIN DID NOT TALK --
HAS NOT TALKED TO US.
>> IT WOULDN'T TAKE THE CALL.
>> EXACTLY, AND I DON'T THINK
THAT IS PARTICULARLY GOOD SIGN
BECAUSE I THINK PEOPLE NEED TO
COMMUNICATE AND LET PEOPLE KNOW
THE UNITED STATES DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING WRONG HERE.
IT WAS CHINA THAT SENT THE
BALLOON THAT CAME INTO OUR
TERRITORY.
AND CHINA HAS NOT HAD A GOOD
EXPLANATION FOR TH